welcome to this video vulvar een yeah
this guy I had played recently and I
don't have this kind of feel something
was wrong there I don't remember exactly
what it was okay again is playing this
in precise movers okay I wonder no I
think I can't play your phone I mean I
takes Queenie voice is very simple okay
so he really doesn't mind that funny I
wonder is there some way to exploit this
hmm Bishop hear me okay it's just a kind
of player was totally it just doesn't
mind to just be a pawn down for nothing
some people are really cool with their
black openings in this vulgar banco kind
of stuff i mean it is just one point
down it has nothing for it and it's
totally relaxed about it it seems ok
let's see any kind of for this is there
any idea like d 575 is coming be 3 or
loop you one yeah yeah maybe d5
ok
questionnaire for I don't know really
don't get any move here I mean it cannot
ever allow me to take on a 60 Maine has
to retreat now on okay so Bishop I can
also go if I for Bishop f3m Bishop c6
hmm it's not bad actually Bishop f4 Jeff
we should perform or a three yards also
quite good night before might be coming
though okay it's a tech t6 key so back
to h3 that's not that great
and chant that uh no I should have
thought about that for one moment I mean
as bad as this all is I mean I cannot
play any nonsense and win and this was
definitely nonsense what I played night
on age 3 is not not happy here I might
get in d5 mmm they're not good
Abby should be six water self pen always
very reluctant to go into those maybe I
can play no yeah that looks really ugly
ugly configuration but okay immediate g4
is not possible and I mean yes weakened
himself quite substantially so if I am
just avoid to lose a piece it is it
should be okay but it was to give
totally unnecessary of course
hmm
not easier
yeah efore hangs so 96-94 maybe I don't
really know and then maybe as chief for
but I can take them I don't know i don't
want to spend more time and get into
more more time pressure Luke cheeks less
kind of loose
that's really really really bad what I
did in this game the whole the whole
thing is not well coordinated at all g4
had this kind of business mp3 mm-hmm I
don't know still this g4 thing is
completely irritating
time warning
bloody night there on age three year
what is silly p check I thought I can
play a fire / TCS is protected that was
really bad ah true not good
and always frustrating are they give you
a winning position after like eight
moves or so and then you screw it up
it's really close to winning everything
else this would be an understatement
it's just a pawn for nothing for totally
nothing and even a good position on top
but I really screwed this up badly I
just need to be aggressive and hope that
some things some things happening here
on the king but I can play Bishop c3 all
the time that didn't see that but he saw
that h5 is hanging
yeah come on white person is probably
going to see Queen edge to meet ya as I
said I just I'm just ah yeah okay well
here I'm just winning up just a pawn for
zip and pip so how did I get how did I
screw this up it's really not easy yeah
I mean getting the night h3 is really
really terrible it's really terrible so
how do I play that what is better here
maybe rupee one rupee one first this is
the kind of thing you just need one or
two precise move and then this thing is
just over but it's not not so easy to do
and let's look you one from the bottom
it's impressionable that this was
correct up to this point now this is
maybe better righty em then 95 or
something yeah yeah okay I'm I was a bit
too optimistic there I mean of course
I'm clearly better this is just a crab
opening but it's not like I'm winning
way I mean it's totally terrible to play
this is black you should know that this
is just crap yeah but still it's not
like I'm winning outright 95 there maybe
hmm how did I play it by the way I'm
here maybe here 95 it's a really this is
this feels right to basically win this
temple on the bishop a he really cannot
let me take it and I mean maybe here
maybe this is the right one were to do
it because these six is also going away
now something like that is probably
refuting it completely
and I computer agrees with that I mean
here this is just I mean I just played
it terrible I mean this is just terrible
getting this half this night down now
this is just not good just not good at
all I mean the way he played it I was so
probably okay again but check it is very
difficult to to coordinate this this
kind of this kind of stuff look before
supposed to be equal check out I mean
it's really not good yeah i was thinking
i was too i really had a blackout really
recall I thought they'll hear but he can
just take and this is this is just too
justyou're bird stuff now I really
played a bad game here the night that I
cannot play it like getting the Knight
to h3 I am then maybe Bishop f4 here
this is what I originally wanted to do
but then I wasn't sure because h6 is
coming Yung a computer just says this is
clearly better
we are probably the computer is giving
it is clearly better for what it's
probably in the case hi this is this is
just just this is just bad I have to I
mean here at least what did i do here
you had this one but then aged six even
here I mean isn't there some way to to
make sense of all of that a three maybe
a 3h six before or something I still
have a hard time to believe I'm gonna
say I'm ready now computer gives us is
equal hmm difficult yeah that's
difficult yeah so there is probably a
relatively small window where I can
totally review this stuff and I didn't I
didn't take this take this opportunity
key i am here 95 is much stronger okay
well thanks for watching